difficult question in 2017 there was a
mosque shooting in Quebec City six
people died five others seriously
injured the 27 year old gunman consumed
a lot of content online
and checked Twitter accounts a lot of a
lot of people but one of the people he
checked quite a lot of is you 93 times
in the month leading up to the shooting
if you could talk to that young man what
would you tell him and maybe other young
men listening to this that have hate in
their heart in that same way what would
you tell them you're getting it wrong
if anything that I or anyone else in
mainstream politics says drives you to
violence you're getting it wrong you're
getting it wrong now again when it comes
to stuff like this I have a hard and
fast rule that I've applied evenly
across the Spectrum and that is I never
blame people's politics for other people
committing acts of violence unless
they're actively advocating violence so
when uh Phantom Bernie Sanders shoots up
a congressional baseball game that is
not Bernie Sanders's fault I may not
like his rhetoric I might disagree with
him on everything Bernie Sanders did not
tell somebody to go shoot up in
Congressional baseball game when a nut
case in San Francisco goes and hits Paul
Pelosi with a hammer I'm not going to
blame Kevin McCarthy the house speaker
for that when somebody threatens Brett
Kavanaugh I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
suggest that that was Joe Biden's fault
because it's not Joe Biden's fault I
mean we can play this game all day long
and I find that the people who are most
intensely focused on playing this game
are people who tend to oppose the
politics of the person as opposed to
actually believing sincerely that this
has driven somebody into the arms of the
the god of violence
but you know I I have 4.7 million
Twitter followers I have 8 million
Facebook followers I have 5 million
YouTube followers I would imagine that
some of them are people who are violent
I would imagine that some of them are
people who do evil things or want to do
evil things
and um I wish that there were a wand
that we could wave that would prevent
those people from deliberately or or
mistakenly misinterpreting things that
are called violence uh it's it's just a
negative byproduct of the fact that you
can reach a lot of people and so
you know if somebody could point me to
the comment that that I suppose quote
unquote drove somebody to go and
literally murder human beings uh then I
would appreciate it so I could so I
could talk about the comment but I I
don't
mainly because I just think that
if we remove agency from individuals
and we if we blame broad scale political
rhetoric for every act of violence We're
Not Gonna the the the people who are
going to pay the price are actually the
the general population because Free
Speech will go away if the idea is that
things that we say could drive somebody
who is unbalanced to go do something
evil
the necessary byproduct is hate is that
is that speech is a form of hate hate is
a form of violence speech is a form of
violence speech needs to be curbed and
that to me is deeply disturbing
so definitely he that man that 27 year
old man is the only one responsible for
the evil he did but what if he and
others like him are not nug cases
what if they're people with pain
with anger in their heart what would you
say to them you are exceptionally
influential and other people like you
that speak passionately about ideas what
do you think is your opportunity to
alleviate the hate in their heart if
we're speaking about people who aren't
mentally ill and people who are just
misguided I'd say to him the thing that
I said to every other young man in the
country you need to find meaning and
purpose in forming connections that
actually matter in in a belief system
that actually promotes
General prosperity and and promotes
helping other people and this is why you
know the message that I most commonly
say to young men is it's time for you to
grow up mature get a job get married
have a family take care of the people
around you become a useful part of your
community
I've I've never at any point in my
entire career suggested violence as a
resort to
political
political issues and the whole point of
having a political conversation is that
it's a conversation if I didn't think
that that it were worth trying to
convince people of my point of view I
wouldn't do what I do for a living
so violence doesn't solve anything no it
doesn't